is in the newsroom
you can tell us more on this is of
course uh we now know that the booster
program is going to be rolled out
to the over 30s from tomorrow that's
right and the booster program and this
new testing regime are all tools in the
government's efforts to combat the very
rapid spread of this new variant let me
tell you a little bit more about this
testing regime that will come into
effect from tuesday so as you rightly
mentioned anyone who is a contact of a
coveted 19 case whether that's the
omicron variant or a different variant
will have to take daily lateral flow
tests for seven days so if at any point
they start developing symptoms or one of
those tests come back positive then they
should take a pcr test to confirm
whether they actually have the virus or
not
if it's positive then they need to
self-isolate for 10 days from the moment
they either develop symptoms or one of
those rapid tests came back positive if
they come negative on the pcr test then
in that case obviously they can leave
quarantine and they should still
continue taking these rapid tests for
the full seven days i think it's worth
mentioning that this only applies to
fully vaccinated people the unvaccinated
individuals will have to quarantine for
full 10 days if they're a contact of a
curved 19 case i mean these these rules
apply just to england as well i think
it's really important to mention in
scotland they are more stringent
there if a member of your household
tests positive for covet 19 that you too
have to isolate for full 10
days now nonetheless here in england the
government says that this will help
significantly to curb the spread of this
variant which they predict will become
dominant by mid-december and with health
authorities saying that potentially one
in three people who have the virus don't
have any symptoms they think this will
really help to try to keep it under
control as much as possible now another
thing that is interesting is what the
government would like to ask people to
do is that if they're identified as a
contact of a code 19 case and they're
taking their lateral flow tests to try
to limit their own contacts with other
people outside the household nonetheless
anyone who may be vulnerable to try to
avoid to going to crowded places or in
close spaces even if they're testing
negative on those daily tests because we
know that it can take some time to
develop curvid and they just want to
make sure that then people not
unwittingly spreading the virus before
it actually gets picked up by the test